Moment.
Hallo, schönen guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Topgös.
Ich bin zuständige Erster für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Marianne Sommerfeld.
Marianne Sommerfeld.
Wie der Sommer und das Feld.
Feld, ja ok.
Ich puh' da wieder einen Namen.
Ihren Vorname ist M, A, R, I, V, I, Da, A, Doppel, N, E.
Genau.
Und Nachname, W, S, O, Doppel, M.
Ja.
E, R, und Bundesstrich F, wie Frankfurt?
Ja, wie Frankfurt, ja.
Ja, E, I, Z.
Ja, F, E, L, D, Sommerfeld.
Ja, Nummer 4.
Wie das Feld.
Es ist Einnahme.
Sommerfeld ist Einnahme ohne Minus, ohne Bindestrich.
Sommerfeld.
Ok, ok.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Sommerfeld.
Freut mich.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62 Jahre alt.
Und wissen Sie aktuell, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, ich bin 1,68 m groß und wiege zur Zeit 80 kg.
80 kg.
Hm, bisschen viel.
Und vielen Dank Frau Sommerfeld.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für mich werden Sie?
Ja, ich habe so ungefähr seit 4 Wochen habe ich zunehmende Luftnot.
Bei Belastung.
Und in den letzten 2 Tagen habe ich auch Luftnot in Ruhe.
Also wenn ich so sitze, ich kann gar nicht flach liegen.
Ich brauche mindestens 3 Kissen, die letzten 2 Nächte habe ich im Sessel geschlafen,
versucht zu schlafen.
Ich habe Husten.
Und meine Beine sind in den letzten Tagen ziemlich geschwollen, ziemlich dick geworden.
Ja, es geht mir nicht gut.
Ok, meine Schwerlungen.
Verstehe.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid zu hören.
Frau Sommerfeld.
Leider Sie ein chronische Erkrankung.
Ich meine Bluthochdruck, Herzunstörungen, vielleicht, Druckerkrankheit.
Ich habe seit 10 Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Und seit 2 Jahren habe ich auch Zucker.
Arztesucker, meinen Sie?
Ja, man sagt, glaube ich, das ist Alterszucker.
Und sonst noch andere, Herzunstörungen vielleicht.
Nein, nur die Leidenerkrankungen, Blutdruck und Zucker.
Haben Sie vielleicht einen Herzinfarkt?
Was, einen Herzinfarkt?
Ja.
Weiß ich nicht.
Schmerzen hatte ich nicht.
Gut.
Aber Sie leiden seit 4 Wochen Atemnot bei Belastung?
Ja, bei Belastung.
Aber in den letzten 2 Tagen auch in Ruhe?
In Ruhe auch, problematisch.
Und Sie haben Gusten?
Ist das Reizgusten oder auch Auswurf?
Kommt auch etwas Auswurf dazu.
Der sieht so schleimig weißlich aus.
Schleimig weißlich.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Vielleicht leiden Sie an Asthma bruschale?
Nein, allergisch bin ich nicht.
Ist nicht bekannt.
Analgae?
Gut.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Beinschwellungen.
Ist das mehr als morgens?
Ja, morgens sind die Beine etwas weniger geschwollen.
Am Abend ist es viel mehr.
Müssen Sie in der Nacht Wasser lassen?
Ja, in den letzten Nächten bis 5 Mal.
5 Mal, okay.
Sie haben seit 2 Jahren Altezucker.
Wie war das Zuckerwert?
Ist das gut eigentlich?
Ich denke, regelmäßig hat Hausärztin die Misszucker-Langzeit-Werte.
Den habe ich im Kopf.
Der war das letzte Mal 6,8.
Da war ich schon ganz zufrieden mit.
Ja, das ist gut.
Frau Sommer, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Nach Schweiß- oder Schutteufrost?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Und Sie haben auch nicht.
Ich habe auch nicht.
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Ich schlafe Sie gut, ich denke nicht.
Nein, in den letzten Nächten habe ich nicht gut geschlafen,
weil ich konnte gar nicht liegen.
Deswegen musste ich im Sessel sitzen.
Da war der Schlaf gar nicht gut.
Gar nicht gut liegen.
Wie lange?
In den letzten 2 Tagen oder 4 Wochen?
Nein, in den letzten 2 Tagen habe ich ja selbst in Ruhe schon Luft.
Da konnte ich gar nicht mehr liegen.
Die Tage vorher konnte ich noch liegen, aber mit 3 Kissen.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber in den letzten Tagen mit der starken Luftnot,
da hatte ich nicht mehr so einen guten Appetit.
Ist Ihnen gewiss Verlust oder zugenommen aufgefallen?
Ja, ich habe in den letzten Tagen nicht mehr so einen guten Appetit.
Ich habe in den letzten 4 Wochen 5 Kilo zugenommen.
Okay, 5 Kilo zugenommen.
Verstehe.
Ich habe auch noch ein starkes Druckgefühl,
rechts im Bauch, unter den Rippen.
Da kann ich mich gar nicht richtig bücken.
Das ist unangenehm.
Das ist wie eine Art Schwellung im Bauch.
Okay, schwellung.
Ich habe noch eine Art Schwellung im Bauch.
Haben Sie Bläungen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Leite Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzklopfen oder Herzstolpern?
Herzstolpern ist bisher nicht bekannt.
Nein, mein Puls ist etwas schneller gegangen.
Ich habe noch eine Art Schwellung im Bauch.
Mein Puls ist etwas schneller gegangen in den letzten Wochen,
seitdem ich diese Luftnot habe.
Da muss mein Herz mehr arbeiten.
Mit Atemnot, das ist normal.
Aber können Sie ohne Pause,
wie viele Treppen steigen?
Müssen Sie eine Treppe?
Müssen Sie nach einer Treppe?
Muss ich Pause machen.
Aber seit zwei Tagen traue ich mir das gar nicht mehr zu.
Da habe ich die Luftnot in Ruhe.
Da habe ich keine Treppen mehr gestiegen.
Frau Sommerfeld,
wegen dieser Probleme,
haben Sie Ihren Hausarzt besucht?
Ich wollte eigentlich,
ich war etwas verreist bei meiner Schwägerin.
Ich war im Urlaub.
Ich hatte mir vorgenommen,
wenn der Husten nicht besser wird und die Luftnot,
dass ich dann zur Hausärztin gehe.
Aber das ist in den letzten zwei Tagen so schlimm geworden.
Jetzt komme ich heute zu Ihnen.
Sie haben gut gemacht,
zu uns kommen.
Frau Sommerfeld, ist Ihnen ein Übel?
Nein, das ist mir nicht.
Haben Sie eine Woche? Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig? Nein.
Gut. Sind Sie unmächtig geworden?
Nein, bin ich bisher nicht.
Gut.
Frau Sommerfeld,
haben Sie eine Idee,
wieso diese schlechte Station
erleiden haben?
Ich hatte vor sechs Wochen
einen Corona-Infekt.
Ob das damit zu tun hat, weiß ich nicht.
Wie wurde es behandelt?
Gar nicht groß.
Ich habe Ruhe eingehalten,
körperliche Ruhe.
Meine Hausärztin hat mich untersucht,
abgehört, hat Blut untersucht.
Es war ein positiver Corona-Test.
Es ging nach einigen Tagen besser.
Danach war der Test negativ.
Frau Sommerfeld,
möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen
für diese kranken Geschichten?
Mein Mann hat gesagt,
dass meine Lippen in letzter Zeit so blicken.
Ich habe die Lippen in letzter Zeit
nicht so aufgefallen.
Aber meinen Mann ist das aufgefallen.
Ihren Finger auch nicht.
Die Kinder leben nicht mehr bei uns.
Nein, ich meine,
Ihren Finger auch nicht.
Nein, ist mir nicht so aufgefallen.
Nein, mehr die Lippen.
Frau Sommerfeld,
ich möchte etwas hinzufügen.
Ich habe ein Zettel,
da nehme ich ein, kann die Satan.
Das steht hinter 8.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine abends.
Dann nehme ich auch ein
Bisoprolol.
5.
2 Mal 1 pro Tag.
Dann nehme ich noch eine Tablette ein.
Davon muss ich oft Wasser lassen.
Ich nehme die morgens ein.
Furose mit.
Da hinter steht 40.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Was nehmen Sie gegen
das Mittel heißt mit vormin.
Da hinter steht 40.
Da hinter steht 850.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens
und eine halbe Tablette abends.
Okay.
Eine halbe abends.
Leiden Sie an die andere kronische Erkrankung?
Nein.
Erhöhte Blutfettwerte?
Was haben Sie als Nationärin geblieben?
Ich bin schon mal im Krankenhaus gewesen.
Wegen Operationen.
Als Kind habe ich einmal eine Operation.
Am Nabelbruch.
Der Nabel war gebrochen.
Nabelbruch und Mandeln.
Das war als Kind.
Wie wurde es behandelt?
Ich habe einen Schritt gemacht.
Vor 12 Jahren hatte ich eine Geilenblasenentfernung.
Ich hatte eine Bauchspeicheltrüsenentzündung.
Da ging es mir gar nicht gut.
Das war durch einen Geilengangstein bedingt.
Daraufhin hat man die Geilenblase operiert.
Ich habe die Geilenblase durchgebracht.
Das war vor 12 Jahren.
Wie war diese Operation?
War das Komplikationslos durch die Bauchspeicheltrüse?
Nein, das ist durch drei Schnitte im Bauch.
Wie man das nennt, Knopfloch-Chirurgie?
Bauchspeicheltrüse.
Und sonst noch andere Operationen?
Nein.
Sie nehmen Kandezerta,
bisoprolol, frosemit, metformin.
Außer diese Tableten.
Sie haben schon gesagt, keine Allergie bekannt bei Ihnen.
Auch die Medikamenteallergie.
Nein.
Leiden Sie an Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich meine, sagen Sie alle Lebensmittel?
Ich vertrag alle Lebensmittel.
Ich muss aufpassen wegen dem Zucker.
Aber ich vertrage alle.
Sie rachen Sie Frau Sommerfeld?
Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol trinke ich 1-2 Glas Wein pro Woche.
Super.
Pro Woche.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, keine Drogen.
Frau Sommerfeld, lebt Ihr Alter noch?
Nein, mein Vater ist im Alter
von 76 Jahren an Herzschwäche verstorben.
Herzschwäche, das tut mir sehr leid.
Die Mutter lebt noch.
Die ist 86 Jahre alt.
Die Mutter hat Asthma.
Und eine schwere Arthrose in beiden Kniengelenken.
Und wie wurde es behandelt?
Die Kniatrose sollte mal operiert werden.
Aber das wollte meine Mutter nicht.
Sie hat da sehr schwer zu tun.
Sie muss an einem Rollator gehen.
Aber sehr mit einem Rollator.
Sie hat eine Schmerz.
Sie möchte sich nicht operieren lassen.
Und haben Sie die Schwester?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Der ist 60 Jahre alt.
Der Bruder hat auch hohe Blutdruck.
Der Bruder hat aber auch hohe Cholesterinwerte.
Okay.
Verstehe.
Frau Sommerfeld, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin sehr Kriterin bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein.
Die Arbeit finde ich nicht stressig.
Aber so seit sind Sie vielleicht krankgeschirrigen?
Ich hatte ja etwas Urlaub.
Und war ja bei meiner Schwägerin.
Und müsste eigentlich in der nächsten Woche wieder arbeiten.
Aber so wie es mir jetzt geht, kann ich das nicht.
Ja, natürlich.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, 30 und 32 Jahre alt.
Die leben aber in anderen Städten.
Und wir sind aber soweit, ich werde es weiß gesund.
Ja, gut. Super.
Sind Sie in Wechseljahr?
Ja, das ist schon längere Zeit.
Das ist so angefangen mit 55,
455.
Aber ich gehe regelmäßig mit Frauenärztin
zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Und die letzte war 3 Monate, das war in Ordnung.
3 Monate vor 3 Monaten.
Und nehmen Sie Ersatztherapie ein?
Nein.
Super.
Ich bin fertig, Frau Sommerfeld.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich mache mir schon Sorgen, was das ist.
Was kann ich denn haben?
Was habe ich ja noch nie gehabt?
Verstehe, Frau Sommerfeld, ich verstehe Ihren Sorgen.
Ich danke Sie, haben eine Herzinsuffizienz.
Deswegen, wir müssen bei Ihnen zuerst
etwas...
Was heißt insuffizienz?
Herzinsuffizienz, Herzversagen.
Oh.
Ja, wegen vielleicht
eine schwere Covid-19.
Und Sie haben chronische Erkrankungen.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Deswegen ist es besser, wenn Sie bei uns behalten.
Okay.
Das können wir so machen.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie einige Minuten Zeit,
sich immer zu bereiten.
Und die Patientensprache in Fachsprache zu übersetzen.
Kollegen, die zugehört zugeschaut haben
und können vielleicht auch Fragen stellen.
Eine Frage taucht hier auf.
Die sehe ich, sind Sie vollständig geimpft.
Ja, meine Hausärztin, die achtet da immer drauf,
dass ich geimpft bin.
Ich bin auch fünfmal gegen Covid geimpft
und habe es trotzdem jetzt gekriegt.
Aber die anderen Impfungen hier für Deutschland sind in Ordnung.
Ich mache auch keine großen Fernreisen.
Ich fahre vielleicht mal in den Ferien,
in die Niederlande oder nach Österreich.
Aber Fernreisen mache ich nicht mehr.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Ich muss sich hier unterbrechen, um die Sauerstoffgaben.
Ja, Sie könnten das machen.
Sie könnten jetzt oder am Anfang bei der Patientin,
wenn Sie sehen, sie ist kurzartig,
könnten Sie natürlich SPU beimesen, den Sauerstoff messen
oder die Patientin an einem Monitor-AKG hängen.
Das könnten Sie gleich zu einem
oder anderen, das könnten Sie gleich zu Anfang machen.
Das war durchaus sinnvoll und wird auch, glaube ich,
von der Prüfungskommission honoriert.
Gut.
Gibt es sonst andere Fragen von anderen Kollegen?
Ich habe eine wichtige Frage gestellt.
Ja, die Kollegin hat ja alle wichtigen Fragen schon gestellt.
Aber vielleicht gibt es noch andere Fragen,
die von Interesse sind oder das ist irgendetwas nicht verstanden worden.
Ich weiß, dass manche Probleme haben mit dem Begriff Nabelbruch.
Aber vielleicht ist das auch gar kein Problem
und wir lösen das gemeinsam, was das heißt.
Das hat sie gefragt?
Ja, Nabelbruch.
Es gibt ja im Bauchraum zwei Brüche, einmal den Leistenbruch.
Der Beufigern.
Das ist der Leistenbruch.
Und dann gibt es noch den Nabelbruch.
Der Nabel heißt wie?
Wie?
Ummilikalis.
Ummilikalherne.
Wie viel Kilo haben Sie zugenommen?
Sie sehe ich da fünf Kilo.
Hat die Patientin zugenommen innerhalb von vier Wochen?
Haben Sie irgendwelche Stuhlveränderungen in letzter Zeit bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich war vor zwei Jahren bei einer Darmspiegelung.
Vorsorge-Darmspiegelung, da war alles in Ordnung.
Aber mein Stuhlgang ist eigentlich immer regelmäßig.
Da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Haben Sie Ihre Haut oder Ihre Augen verändert bemerkt?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, ich habe auch keinen Yukreiz oder so.
Das lediglich ist mir aufgefallen,
dass meine Beine besonders abends sehr stark geschwollen sind.
Die Frage da unten, kann ich nicht komplett lesen.
Fühlen Sie sich wahrscheinlich erschöpft?
Müttekeitserschöpfung.
Ja, also dass die Luftnot der letzten Wochen
und besonders der letzten Tage hat mich schon erschöpft.
Ich konnte ja auch gar nicht mehr richtig schlafen die letzten Nächte.
Also ich fühle mich jetzt schon ziemlich erschöpft und müde.
Gül, können wir anfangen?
Ja, ich frage mich.
Die Kollegin weiß alles.
Ja, danke Herr Oberass.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Es geht um Frau Mariana Sommerfeld.
Sie ist 62-jährige Patientin,
seitlich örtlich und persönlich orientiert,
in leicht übergewichtigen Ernährungszustand
und in diesem Jahr bedingt ich dortlich reduzierten Algemeinszustand.
Frau Sommerfeld, ich stelle für uns vor,
aufgrund seit vier Wochen, 5 Jahren, 2 Jahren,
am Anfang bei Belastung abhängige Düsbne.
Aber in zweit sagen, auch in Ruhe, Düsbne,
die des Weiteren klagte sie über,
Reizusten, 5 Mal Nectary.
Der Reizusten ist der Trocken oder ist der...
Trocken, nein, ist auch mit Auswurf, schleimige und weiße Auswurf.
Okay.
Ja, außerhalb haben sie wegen dieser Düsbne,
in Somni, insbesondere in Zweitzage, in Somni,
oder in der Patiente, in der sie normal ist,
nicht so viel, aber in der vier Wochen haben sie 5 kg
Zugenommen gehabt habe.
Okay, zugenommen, ja.
Ja, darüber hinaus habe ich bein ödem bemägt.
Ja, ja...
Ist das bein ödem tageszeitlich abhängig?
Ja, natürlich, aber abends mehr als ich.
Okay.
Ja, zudem, ja,
laut, laut,
ein Moment, laut,
der Patiente,
habe sie, in letzter Zeit,
ist Psyanose am Lippen.
Ja, können Sie uns...
Der Ehemann habe eine Lippenzyanose bemerkt.
Ja, ja, ja,
außerhalb haben sie ihren Bauchumfang,
vergoßerte Bauchumfang bemerkt.
Ja, auch die Brücke gefühlt.
Die Patiente hat gesagt, ein Druck gefühlt.
Gefühlt, rechtsseitige,
Hypo-kondrial-Region.
Ja, woran würden Sie da denken, was das sein kann?
Wegen die Hypotomegalie,
wegen die heißen Psyanose.
Hypatomegalie, ja?
Ja.
Kann sich wahrscheinlich um eine Leberstaubung handeln?
Im Sinne einer Hypatomegalie.
Gut.
Haben Sie die Vitalparameter bei der Patientin,
weil sie doch in einem reduzierten Allgemeinzustand ist,
mit Orthopne,
haben Sie die Vitalparameter anfangs kontrolliert?
Ja, ich habe kontrolliert.
Sie war ein bisschen taktikadisch,
wegen dieser Atemnot.
Aber Blutdruck, bisschen höher.
Und SPO2?
SPO2 war niedriger, war 90%.
Ja, gut.
Deswegen gebe ich ihr Sauerstoff gehabt.
Okay.
Gut, das kann man machen.
Gut, danke.
Hat die Patientin chronische Erkrankungen
oder in der letzten Zeit eine Erkrankung erlebt?
Ja, sie habe schon seit sechs Wochen
eine Covid-19 erleiht.
Okay.
Deswegen als mögliche Ausflöse
diese Covid-19.
Okay, das kann sein.
Ja, okay.
Gut, gibt es Kohleerkrankungen?
Ja, ja, sie haben, sie leiden an
arteriorealhypertonisatienjahren.
Okay.
Und auch die Diabetes-Militistip 2 seit 2 Jahren.
Da gegen benutzte sie mit Formen 845 mg 2 Mal.
Einmal morgens, ein halber Tablete abends.
Okay, okay.
Und gegen Bluthochdruck nehmen sie ein Kandesertal 8 mg 2 Mal.
Täglich 2 Mal.
Und bisoprolol 5 mg 2 Mal.
Und pro Somet 40 mg einmal morgens.
Ja, gut.
Und sie wurde operiert, als Kind sie eine umrikallherne
und deswegen sie musste operiert operieren.
Ja, sie musste operiert werden.
Sie musste operiert werden.
Ja.
Sie war 12 Jahren, deswegen eine, ja, wegen einer
Kohlesistolitis.
Nein, nein, nein, sie hatte als Kind 2 Operationen.
Ja, 12 Jahre geilen Blasen, entweder.
Nein, nein, vor 12 Jahren war das.
Als Kind hatte sie 2 Operationen.
Bach, Speichel, Entzündung.
Nein, nein, als Kind, als Kind in der Kindheit.
Vielleicht Trostelectomy.
Genau, sie hatte die umrikallherne und sie hatte eine Tonsylektomie.
Das war als Kind.
Das war als Kind, ja.
Und vor 12 Jahren hatte sie was.
Was war vor 12 Jahren?
Bach, Speichel, Entzündung.
Pankreatitis.
Eine akute Pankreatitis.
Wir legen eine geilen Blasenstein.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wegen einer Choleletiasis.
Und danach musste sie geilen Blasen entzellen.
Danach wurde eine Choletsystektomie durchgeführt,
eine laparoscopische Choletsystektomie.
Ja, also wichtiges akute Pankreatitis,
wahrscheinlich aufgrund einer Choleletiasis.
Und anschließend dann im Intervall
eine laparoscopische Choletsystektomie.
Gut.
Okay.
Die Fragen nach Allagi wurden verneint.
Sie sei nicht rauchig, aber sie trinken ein bis zwei Gläserwein
in der Woche.
Ja.
Konzen wurden verneint.
Sein Vater sei...
Ihr Vater, ja.
Ja, ich schuldige.
Ihr Vater sei an Herzinsuffizienz verstorben.
Ja.
Und in welchem Alter, wie alt war der Vater da?
Ja, mit 76 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Ihre Mutter, leider an, Asthma Bronschale
und Beidseitige, Grunartros, schweren Grad Grunartros.
Sie soll operieren lassen, aber sie will nicht.
Öchter das nicht.
Wie alt ist die Mutter?
86 Jahre alt.
Gut.
Sehr gut.
Sie habe auch einen Bruder und sie leide an
Artillerie Hypertonie und erhöhte Hyperlipidämie.
Ja, oder Hypercholesterinämie.
Beide gleich.
Bei Hyperlipidämie würden wir eventuell noch die Triglyzuride
mit dazunehmen.
Der Bruder hat jetzt nur hohes Cholesterin.
Da würde ich ruhig sagen Hypercholesterinämie.
Hypercholesterinämie, okay.
Aber Hyperlipidämie ist jetzt auch nicht falsch.
Aber Hypercholesterinämie wäre wahrscheinlich in diesem Fall
etwas genauer.
Ja.
Okay, danke.
Sie sei Sekretärin bei der Imrechtsanwalt.
Ja, bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Sie arbeitet als Sekretärin bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Sie sei zufrieden.
Sie sei verheiratet und wohne mit ihrem Mann zusammen.
Sie haben zwei gesunde erwachsene Kinder.
Gut, prima.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Herzinsuffizienz.
Die annamnistische Angaben deuten am ersten auf.
Herzinsuffizienz in.
Differenzial diagnostisch.
Ja.
Die Diagnostik.
Aber Hypotheorien.
Hypotheorien.
Natürlich.
Akute Coronasandrum.
Die Frau, man muss nicht vergessen.
Gut, ich würde fast den Verdacht stellen.
Nicht nur auf eine Myokatinsuffizienz,
sondern auf eine dekompensierte Myokatinsuffizienz.
Die hat die Patientin eine ausgeprägte Ruhedisplö.
Ja.
Das würde ich schon sagen.
Da kommt das gerade im Chat.
Myokatitis, aber Fieber keine.
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch viele Myokatidin.
Da fragen wir den Kardiologen.
Es gibt ja auch Myokatidin ohne Fieber.
Das ist ja der Gemein an einer Myokatitis,
weil sie hat manchmal die klinischen Symptome sind.
Manchmal so sehr unscharf.
Aber eine Post-Covid-Myokatitis sollte in diesem zeitlichen Zusammenhang
zumindest in Erwägung gezogen werden.
Aus Covid-Myokatitis.
Und sie hat begleitend eine Hepatomegalie
am der dekompensierten oder ausgeprägten Myokatinsuffizienz.
Prima.
Ja, danke.
Haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Ich habe Sie auch gut verstanden.
Sie haben das sehr gut strukturiert.
Und Sie konnten, fast alle Begriffe haben Sie gekonnt.
Sie haben etwas überlegt.
Sie konnten sich gut erschließen.
Danke.
Das war sehr gut.
Denken Sie ruhig dran.
Bei so einem Fall würde ich gleich zu Anfang vielleicht sagen,
Sie sehen ja die Patientin,
die Lipentziornose hat.
Sie haben eine Ruhe displö, hat das Sie gleich?
Ja, ja.
Ich muss unterherfällig sofort.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich einige Werte bei Ihnen haben.
Da bin ich mir sicherer auch.
Ich möchte, dass es Ihnen hier gut geht.
Und da honorieren die Patienten auch.
Das ist eine Art Ausbildung.
Gleich Blutdruckmessen,
SPO2, eventuell etwas Sauerstoff geben,
dass die Patienten auch merken, ich werde ernst genommen.
Das kümmert sich jemand um mich.
Das wäre noch mal so,
wir sagen noch mal,
und top.
Das ist gut gemacht.
Also so würden Sie, glaube ich, diese Prüfung gut bestehen.
Ich auch.
Danke.
Vielen Dank.
Okay.
Zur nächsten Wort.